es momento de hablar de la información
económica aquí en France 24 hoy
dedicaremos esta sección para hablar del
proyecto de reforma laboral de Colombia
propuesto por el gobierno del presidente
Gustavo Petro un proyecto que se suma a
la polémica reforma a la salud y que
tendrá un largo camino por recorrer con
las modificaciones que le hagan los
legisladores en el congreso el proyecto
de 37 páginas y nueve capítulos en su
primera parte ha llamado la atención de
los ciudadanos la opinión pública y
analistas económicos por tres puntos
importantes el primero Es sobre la
modalidad de contratación en donde se
habla de los tipos de contratos del fin
de los contratos por prestación de
servicios y la búsqueda de que la
mayoría de estos contratos lleguen a
término indefinido el segundo sobre las
horas extra los dominicales y festivos
en donde se plantea una reducción
importante en las horas de trabajo para
los colombianos y el último sobre las
plataformas digitales que ha sido muy
polémico pues pide una regulación de
Estos tipos de trabajo y le exige a las
aplicaciones o sitios web regular toda
la labor de sus empleados para hablar de
este tema nosotros hablamos también con
Javier Eduardo almanza coordinador del
área laboral y seguridad social de la
Universidad de Rosario de Bogotá
Colombia quien nos contó que este
proyecto de reforma laboral es
importante para el país sudamericano
Bueno lo primero que hay que considerar
de esta reforma es primero que no es
definitiva segundo va a tener ajustes la
reforma busca inicialmente
de trabajadores el empleador pero el
mejoramiento inicialmente de las
condiciones hay que reconocer y recordar
que también debe haber una transición y
cualquier implementación normativa
resultado de su implementación normativa
es innegable el aumento de pronto de
costo para un trabajador por parte del
empleador pero también tengo un ejemplo
en particular la reducción de la jornada
laboral puede llevar en un determinado a
una mejora de las condiciones de vida
del
sin embargo también hay que mirar el
contrapeso para el empleador Esas son
las implicaciones que puede tener qué va
a llevar eso una posible desaceleración
de la contratación es probable mientras
se genera ese punto de equilibrio porque
no podemos desconocer las condiciones
actuales de la economía es global ha
tenido un pequeño golpe tal como lo
decía nuestro invitado repasemos ahora
los puntos clave de esta reforma el
recargo laboral de jornadas dominicales
y festivas tendrá una remuneración del
100% sobre el salario ordinario y no del
75 como se tenía anteriormente se
propone que el inicio de la jornada
nocturna sea a las 18 horas y no a las
21 horas como se tenía también
anteriormente se propone también que el
máximo de horas trabajadas a la semana
sea de 42 horas horas que se pueden
distribuir en cinco o seis días con el
empleador un negocio que se hace
directamente con el empleador La
regulación de las plataformas entre
muchas cosas buscará las que las
personas que trabajen en dichas
plataformas sean consideradas como
trabajadores y Por ende que accedan a
derechos laborales como de seguridad
social el aporte a las pensiones y
seguros y también el riesgo laboral si
para los contratos fijos inferiores a un
año Por ejemplo ninguna de las partes
avisa la otra parte también deberá
continuar con un contrato indefinido no
se podrá contratar por modalidad de
prestación de servicios a personas que
van a realizar actividades permanentes y
subordinadas y también revisamos como
todos estos cambios son relacionados con
otros países de América Latina Esto fue
lo que nos dijo a nivel comparativo de
América de América Latina
particularmente las disminuciones de la
jornadas han sido en proporción a lo que
se está presentando en el contexto
internacional es decir Buscar bajar de
las 48 horas tradicionales en la hora de
la generación de las jornadas
colombianas con ese desmonte progresivo
que se ha presentado hasta llegar a las
42 en el 2026 aproximadamente eso busca
generar cierta paridad con países como
latinoamérica como México en el Brasil
eventualmente Incluso en Norteamérica
frente a la jornada máxima que pueda
tener un trabajador buscando y pensando
también no solo en la actividad
empresarial sino también en la calidad y
la condición de vida de los trabajadores
si hay que recordar y no podemos
desconocer que la Salud Mental y la
salud física ha sido puesta a prueba y
para el tema de las plataformas
digitales un tema que también ha sido
muy polémico nuestro invitado nos habló
acerca de cómo Colombia desea avanzar en
este proceso desea regular a los
trabajadores y que también tengan todo
el panorama necesario para que su labor
tenga este derecho laboral precisamente
hablamos de la seguridad social de
pensiones y de riesgos laborales hicimos
la comparación con otros países de
Europa y también Estados Unidos en donde
en esos lugares La regulación ya ha
tenido un progreso aún más este tema de
las plataformas digitales y de las
aplicaciones ha sido muy polémico en
Colombia Por qué en los países del Mundo
ha tenido que pasar todo un proceso
judicial para el reconocimiento de un
trabajador a través de una plataforma
digital Europa Norteamérica en
Latinoamérica en particular países
cercanos inicialmente han tenido que
llegar a procesos judiciales a su máximo
órgano de cierre para determinar que
ellos estas personas desarrollan la
actividad a través de una plataforma
digital son verdaderos trabajadores sin
embargo en Colombia el fenómeno es
contrario a través de esta reforma lo
que se está haciendo es darle la
categoría de trabajador a esta persona
que desarrolla la actividad que nos
puede llevar en algún momento a una
general generar una nueva categoría de
trabajadores que serían los de
plataformas digitales y adicional lo que
sí Considero que se quedó no corto pero
debe complementarse actualmente sería la
categoría de trabajador porque la
naturaleza de ellos no es no es
permanente y entraríamos a discutir
ciertos aspectos técnicos del pago de la
seguridad social
un tema que se seguirá revisando en
Colombia por ahora es toda la
información que tenemos a nivel
económico pero sigan ustedes con más
aquí en France 24 y France 24.com